all right I'm only about four hours late
this is an eight hour long tournament
the yearly rapid arena and so it's up
okay Lance 5500 is leading the
tournaments the over a hundred points
I'm not going to try and win the
tournaments I'm just going to try and
make this instructive I try and survive
at least a few games of play Knight f3
ready opening this guy have a real
rating alright so relatively beginner
player and because I'm joining late I
think what will happen is I'll play like
a lot of low rated players at the
beginning and then I'll gradually play
stronger players so hopefully it'll be
interesting playing Knight c3 usually
you white should move the C pawn before
playing Knight c3 now I don't think this
is a move I can punish but I think I'll
just play like a reverse London setup
there's some case where I might play
Bishop to b4 so just pin the knight
Bishop d3 Bishop g6 I'm happy if we
trade at the H file hello to stock this
first-person chat welcome this is common
with a lot of like new players they see
a check they give a check I think this
one we helps black completing my my very
solid setup I'm not sure where this
Bishop wants to go but I'm sure where
this light wants to go let's play 97
probably Bishop d6 coming next
and yeah there's still a few more moves
I can play it to complete the setup and
I think what I'll do is eventually play
e5 if nothing too drastic happens b3 b3
very weakening to c3 whites basically
asking for Bishop b4 queen a5
the thing is Bishop to t2 I can't really
punish it like like forcing me to wing
material
there's also 94 ideas but we just trade
in Bishop before Bishop here before it
takes ticks hmm let's just continue
Bishop d6 I don't want to overthink
anything hello to more people in the
chat I do have a driver's license no one
person asking and I'm streaming in a
reasonable hour it's 2 p.m. my last
stream was at like 1 a.m.
who's saying allo has one 337 hello tog
e7 the singing Mountain doctor drunken
Steen with two N's RAF Rica Bracken
Dawson is to see everyone dead man hello
hello 7:00 p.m. in Iceland not bad
I would assume it's it's lights is it
lighting in Iceland this time of year
it's like getting to that point where
it'll be lights like all the time night
h4 very positional again I'm not too
concerned about like opening h-file
would actually look forward to that
considering playing this smooth a let's
play the smooth
trying to open up the center love
together Knight to e5 I am allowing
Knight f5 Knight f5 there's some funny
line 905 Bishop to b4 i takes g7 King f8
and then both Knights would be attacked
okay so we're trading each files open so
white probably doesn't want a castle
castling just runs into efore and h2
will fall Queen e2 also a mistake before
the bishops now trapped life is good
as Morales in the chat 10 p.m. in Turkey
nice from Spain como estas
oh it is bright
yeah I went to Iceland once like over
the summer like mid-june and like it was
still light around midnight but on my
plane ride to Iceland I saw the Northern
Lights it was like a miracle it's
incredible
the bishop takes I don't know if the
bishop takes I'll probably take with mmm
probably with pawn I could trade but
this light is still a bit clumsy on c3
it's bits from stock this thing's for
the bit stock this 300 bits not sure if
I'm supposed to shake this let's say
shake must keep refrigerated it's vegan
I got this as Whole Foods one thing I've
ever had this before some some kind of
toasted almond coconut chai non GMO
vegan sugar-free lots of words see how
it is it's not bad a little bit spicy it
should be 5 I should probably take the
bishop I mean this is also kind of a
nice move let's take the bishop
expecting that takes and then then maybe
Bishop before Chuck I'm trying to
provoke c3 and then the night will be a
little bit stuck
I could trade to trade them in castle
let's do that
okay it's still sort of waking up last
night's dream was maybe a bit too long
yeah this is just a matter of converting
and usually when you're on material I
mean the kind of standard plan is to
trade I think my plan will be to keep
pieces on the board an attack or
charming more material because this
night is still still a target not
defended if Queenie - Queenie - defends
a knight okay this is what I want to see
so now the king is very attackable let's
start with Queen Queen b6 so it's
obvious I want to rock on ch wow how c4
let's play this move hit the pawn also
pin the pawn threatening Queen takes be
fine I move the F rook to see it because
Eric could maybe serve some purpose
okay now White's position is crumbling
the night will be the night is
undefended and pinned and if a for I
mean I could take a four I could buy a
six I'll be up two pieces two nights
I'll still have a a monster attack wait
what about Greek spinach pie ah a
spanakopita I've had that before it's
pretty good
if anyone brings me that I'll be very
thankful for that Greek gift checkmates
pretty sure I've heard of checkmate but
checkmate spelled sees eech still heard
of it I have a Czech friend I wanted to
like get them a shirt that says check me
spelled that way let's take the knight
more bits from as Morales I'm rated 1359
and chest comm what book would you
recommend for someone around that rating
13:59 um on chess calm there's so many
books out there I mean if you're a kid
there's a great book I recommend for
kids called so called winning chess
strategy for kids by Jeff Coakley it's
also good for adults and go to my book
recommendations and see what I recommend
ooh more free material recommendations
yeah I mean I would probably recommend
the tactics book there's a lot of
tactics books I can recommend it depends
what you want to work on so one book
I've been recommending recently called
forcing moves it's by Charles hurting
it's all about like forcing calculations
tactical sequences
wait is this force means if I move there
here here here and then mate but after
King d6 our King b5 okay this will be a
nice mate Keeney five rookie six mates
okay
nice game a nice finish yeah my opponent
I mean and she played a game kind of
resembling the reigning like it's normal
or did attempted to do some normal
opening played some slightly dubious
moves Knight c3 Bishop b5 check and and
eventually fell victim to just some
simple tactic that's usually how you
beat players like around this reigning
just play solid wait for the opportunity
to to strike either with tactics or with
like blunders okay I got a big raid what
why am I not I should have my
notifications open waits hey you're
awake and you're alive nice you have
work today
whoa
have you heard of Envy oh yeah he raided
me party of 299 thanks I'm do appreciate
it I played tennis with MDL a few months
ago it was fun I was a lowest rated
player on the tennis courts as MDL cause
I'm John of korilla even higher rated
than me
and it's chess bay what's up chess Bay I
did notice a raid thanks for letting me
know I don't have a tennis rating I'm
not that good actually I probably do
tennis ratings just scale from like one
to five right I think I'm like a four
pretty sure I'm a four so I have a
friend who's like a bit better than me
he's a 4.5 ok I'm playing another person
so we're climbing the rating ladder
rated 1708 let's play e4 I try and be
slightly aggressive I don't think I've
ever played Wii Sports tennis wonder if
it's like real tennis I played table
tennis yeah I played table tennis
actually a couple of days ago
with the laws loophole guy who's like in
his 70s but he's really good
just upload some video of that b6 so
this is what is this called a Larson
opening it has a passive reputation I'm
gonna start with Knight c3 so I have a
setup in mind where I'm assuming a six
so what most people like d6 new six is a
bit strange okay let's play d4 I mean
black might be just going for like a
hedgehog or not a hedgehog a hippo
getting my animals confused yeah I'm
just gonna develop normally there might
already be some ideas of taking my g5 e
sixes probably pretty illogical and one
of the best ways to try and like break
down the setup is to use your rock pawns
like if I get an a5 it's actually
annoying for a black to deal with a5 a6
Bishop could be attacked maybe I'll trap
another Bishop Bishop c6 d 5
didn't Fisher and Karpov play tennis I
think there's a lot of chess players
that play tennis at least mark a sermon
being mark a sermon is probably the best
like titled chess player at tennis his
youtube channel is amazing it's just
like chess and tennis videos a six
alright so I think I can take and move
back add something back still equal
material there's a slight weakness on a
six maybe I'll play Queen e2 but again
like similar till the last game I'm just
trying to be solid not to to many fancy
things except h4 looks really fancy
that's my h4 and the same strategy but
on the Kings side I want to play h5 if
black plays h5 and I can play Bishop g5
and there's no more playing each six
squares under my control
I could consider Bishop f6 here Bishop
f6 rook g8 Queen e2 let's do it now the
position is just a little bit passive
our cast to move Queenie to will come
with initiative if a five eventually
then maybe someday there should be five
if Tenace had feed a ratings what would
mine be I mean I played in high school
I was like probably better than average
but not like serious I mean I'd say like
seventeen eighteen hundred this was
probably reasonable nowhere near like
master level but it's something um takes
okay so I could win the pawn the problem
with taking the pawn is there's a pin
which I probably don't want to deal with
could retreat the bishop we're treating
actually looks nice I don't really want
to trade pieces because wax very cramped
taking also looks nice keeps initiative
trying to evaluate like if this Bishop
can actually hurt me so the pawns
defended of c-5 mean taken rip D one
swipe of g5
I want to keep the bishop for future
play thanks for the comment no / what
does this mean no / mabye on please
hey Rosen I was watching you from
YouTube for a long time appreciate how
calm you are whatever happens I don't
know about whatever happens his points
where things happen
I lose my calmness but it doesn't happen
too often just pay thanks for subbing
for 3 months
appreciate that chess pay o get profit
is back with the extension wait let me
copy this I'll copy this to another
window wait get profit I'm gonna just
mod you so you can share links in one
sec imma get profits just share links
that are related to the whatever the
code I do appreciate it
I hear okay so he's trying to hurt my D
pawn could play d5 d5 takes if I could
open d5 and like move in let's play d5
if Knight moves in we trade take on g6
hey it's bits o R enigma thanks for the
bits I don't have to take good care and
leave all the tension
what's castle I want the rooks connected
so I can take the pawn and not have to
fear any pin
ish requesting a French I could play a
French in honor of MVL I mean I'm not
like a French expert sir anything okay
f6 so black has one connect for this
Bishop is now slightly sad I could take
and play my tea for just got some
counter play against the Queen Queen g4
we could trade I mean there's a bunch of
good-looking options here I'm
calculating some line like take stakes
mighty for queen g4 f3 Queen moves in
[Music]
let's start with taking
I might just move back make Bishop f4
it's still very much of fights like
honestly I thought my opponent was gonna
collapse earlier but it's equal material
in black has some weaknesses so I have
to prove the position I mean the goal is
to play 94 eventually I mean immediate
threats probably just taking follow
people requesting openings Carol Khan
requested and MBL makes it sound like
something happened to him did something
happen to MDL hopefully thoughts I mean
it's just in honor of his his raid
Queeny seven so I could take I could
maybe I should take your first and then
take your feels wrong giving away the
bishop pair but the night was just so
annoying there now I'll take here we'll
trade some more and this bishop is just
now blocked d5 could be a nice square
for a knight Danish gambit okay I'm
gonna play a French the first
opportunity so I haven't played the
French in a while I forgot what it's
like to play a French
wait let me paste this codon Oh No I
lost the code get profit can you share
the link again now you can share an
actual link because you're a mod okay oh
thanks open whoa
okay move that over there nice
oh it's available in the Chrome Web
Store really add to Chrome actually is
there some like rule about adding
extensions to leech us maybe a leech s
admin can tell me because I know there's
certainly chess extensions you add and
then you get banned immediately so I
don't want that to happen but what I do
want to have happen so salt against the
King okay there's a bunch of like I'm
amazing looking moves here in the Queen
here
I'm a here but there's one simple
combination rook takes pawn tix and then
rook a7 and life is good yeah sometimes
this is what happens like the game is a
fight you have to poke and prod create
weaknesses and then the tactics and the
material will eventually come this
extension is safe good to hear my
opponent resigned also good to hear yeah
I mean I think around here I saw that
was gonna be a fight and then the game
ended five moves later I mean a six
probably needed some babysitting
maybe queen c8 it's ugly but sometimes
you got to do what you got to do
I mean I'd see for a bit more active
and I guess I could still take yeah a
five maybe also playable does a lot
Bishop e5 and c6 but yeah this is not a
recommended opening I know it's may be
simple to play but white just has all
the fun all right I'm getting challenges
wait dr. Tournament I'll add the you add
this to Chrome now if i refresh refresh
hey I have the accept random challenge
button I'll try it out later because I'm
playing a tournament I want to ruin my
my streak so far nice spring weather
wait where are you from sockless you're
not in Iceland are you
it was Iceland person that was tog II
another loons yeah the weather has been
really good in st. Louis until like
yesterday just started storming now
there's flood warnings so here I can't
play a French I've gone down on the
ladder 1588 I'll still try and make this
instructive I'll play in the same style
solid a reasonable chess well play
Bishop e5 check this is one of the most
challenging lines for luck
the point is after anything blocks I
played Bishop c4 and the Queen's no
longer attacking the pawn now I have to
remember the slide I gave a whole
lecture about the sonim the st. Louis
chess club YouTube channel I know it
starts with f3 Bishop c8 if you like
this guy his books and I know the plan
is listen this I think I'm just supposed
to allow it they gotta play Knight c3 my
t7 will come and if I call if I recall
correctly it's just a slight advantage
for white likes light the pleasant lady
for unfortunate I can't really defend
upon unless I play this move than a 6
I'm actually looking for ways to like be
creative here like this in this that
looks way too extreme but maybe it's
playable by Queen e2 Knight b6 and Queen
d3 only square to the fender things
I'm searching for like problems like how
does black punish me if I do this when
there's take stakes but my pawns still
defended and I guess because I don't see
anything immediate let's do it let's see
how black reacts Queen d3
it looks very unusual I mean usually the
pollen should be on d4 I know I've
played something or something line like
this before but I just play d4 and it's
a bit more normal but here I'm being
greedy trying to hold on to my pony I'm
not sure what lock is gonna do there
might be some long-term compensation
chapter Russia what does this name
cheburashka one two three four five
galaxy VSG yes I'm coming to the normal
Congress actually I think the
information is up I should put in my
schedule g6 is honestly the move that I
was that I would play myself if I was
black because this is a really annoying
threat
I could play g4 there's some crazy line
like 92 Bishop f5 there should be five
c6 and then takes I soccer clean when I
went it back looks too crazy
g4 hmm d4 might be too extreme but don't
stop Bishop f5
okay I'm playing g4 I'm not even getting
a bribe to do it I'm just trying to be
restrictive I want to put a knight on f4
just make sure the pawn is variable
defended yeah if you guys want to see
this tournament that I'm playing in it's
in a few weeks it's the st. Louis norm
Congress just go to us chess champs calm
I don't think they have the field but
they do have the um actually they do
have the pairings h5 man
some scary move so g5 Bishop f5 Queen d4
and the knight is actually pinned it's
by g5
I mean maybe the line keeps going Bishop
a5 Queen d4 Knight takes e4 pawn takes
f6 Knight has to move back to some
square I take here this is just a mess
but I'm up upon the Knights pinned I
think this is only move otherwise I just
win material now we'll see what happens
way too bad I'm not coming coming to
where Calgary oh yeah I've I have a lot
of travel coming up I'm going to Chicago
I think this afternoon actually
and then California next week anyone in
the chat will be at the the PCL finals
it's like in a couple of weeks whoa
Knight takes e4 okay let's wait this is
actually a serious decision I could take
here I can take here 2x here because
it's still forcing like 96 ticks ticks
92 I'm still attacking the rook still up
upon if I take here this line has to
move 97 and maybe like d4 or even d3
yeah I couldn't like this better
cousin lights a bit awkward keep things
simple my play just d3 very soon no joke
might start playing the sign is black
it's not a bad line if you want
something simple again c4 not too many
white players are preparing instance
myself kind of included but I think
things are still under control he's been
finding some interesting moves like g6
and h5 or are definitely intriguing Omid
asking what would you recommend in the
early C takes d4 Knight red lines in
London for the white side take a look at
was it it was black necking take a look
at calm ski Nakamura from us
championship I think it was the last
time are the most recent time they
played in u.s. championship I could find
the game coughs he played a really
interesting pawn sack line I think
there's lots of room for like
preparation in that line night h7 very
happy to see this in 97 and then I mean
keeping the lights centralized was a
better a better approach now I can play
d3 support the pawn and now I'm ready to
play like Bishop f4 and like b5 and okay
White's gonna have some nice harmony so
you come from Chomsky Nakamura best
championship chess games because it's
probably 2017
they drew really quickly but the opening
was fascinating alright see ya
I'll try yeah this game
yeah just learn the theory through like
g4 h4 and also like I would actually
recommend using stock fish to to analyze
it because there's a lot of ways that
can go wrong in that line anyway let's
focus on the game at hand it's still a
fight going on I'm up upon I could win
another pawn but it's probably not a
great option like I mean d5 so it's just
complete development expecting castling
but then the rights like just completely
stuck tell us about st. Louis are you a
bra now this has says hammer I have a
command now that explains the whole bra
situation you can type in what's the
command of why bras why bras in the chat
there we go
so I did move to Canada which some
people assume and not officially a chest
bra it was funny because I posted on
April 1st by moving to this apartment
everyone thought it was April Fool's I
mean I could on passant in honor of
being French
but I'm not even French well that's like
the most French thing I can do because
it happens on the e6 square I'm so
conflicting let's do it
and Queen a4 I'm gonna be greedy try and
grab as many pawns as possible
hey it's bits from Henry Lord watan
realizing I played g5 stepping in for
love hey chess I appreciate that
yeah g5 was it was a key move it's
always a key move I also played g4 like
g4 is always the first step to playing
g5 alright so I could take upon um it
allows this I mean maybe I should just
play h4 like just defend ya keep the
knight completely restricted I should
focus on my time too
apart from just reading the chat not
sure that's exactly how you become a bra
no joke but maybe he's not joking I
don't actually know the official like
procedures anyway positions looking good
time is leveling out good queenside
castle when these bishops are kind of
scary
mm I mean I know the structure looks
relatively solid good Knights defend
each other if I get the chance I want to
play Bishop t-62a three just have the
bishops it's I don't think I'll be
dyeing my hair at least any time soon I
want to do this we need three ideas
I could play King me one I could play d4
d4 kind of looks nice what else to do
I'll play Bishop III at some points
I'll play Bishop d6 if Queenie
three-inches King b1 rook da Queen at
four my whole idea is to put the Queen
on f4 oh there's Bishop takes a two it's
kind of weird
so maybe King b1 first or maybe T 4 and
then Bishop GT for looks nice here
trying to block this Bishop creates some
control over c5 also I'd use a Bishop e5
yeah what's the difference between a bra
a bra and a bro it's just too confusing
it's like it's like a street a Bulevar
and an avenue they're all pretty much
the same thing right okay rook e1 just
defend
get all my pieces are doing something at
least I still want to play Bishop c5
wait you just gave me a free bishop
I didn't take it I was not expecting a
gift I was so like focused on a
difference between bras and Bros and
bras I mean I'm still up a pawn can't
complain so much
but this is gonna come down to the end
this is not the most high-quality game
not the most high-quality commentary and
you apologize for the viewers all right
most important question
what's a cheburashka that like a chest
bra I don't even know it's not trying to
figured things out
Bishop c5 still in the air I move the
knight first good move in the night
first
efore looks nice very stable access to
f6 d6 c5 and I'm almost finally up on
time oh it's a Soviet cartoon
interesting okay
very interesting play Queen a3
I mean blacks essentially down a piece
here with this night on each seven and
if it ever moves and f6 is available
like if takes else imagine takes takes
never mind
mmm could take first some weird move
like takes takes and then Knights here
I'm losing back upon but I want to get
the night at 6:00 yeah this is this is a
time scramble it's kind of a slow time
scramble both love minutes still taking
time on us and the chats
what's the Mamas people saying don't
flag but don't tell that to my opponent
you can tell it to me let's check your
key one oh there's some very nice
amazing idea
Queen takes f8 King takes f8 rook Yates
to g8 will have happen actually don't
want him to flag now well it's gonna
happen Queen takes f8 Nathan Nathan to
next Jack and I'm so glad my opponents
in the flag
I was so satisfying well they finished
such a nice finish to such a low quality
I missed a free bishop I don't know how
I missed the free bishop it's too many
distractions my opponent was playing
pretty well for the most part I just was
not expecting Bishop c4 or not in
expecting like such a bad move but the
finish kind of made up for it
Queen sock I have a question for you
Eric what do you think of someone what
do you think if someone with say 20
viewers raids you when you have 200 or
500 viewers do you raid me I'm getting
distracted by so many things um oh maybe
you didn't raid me but it's still nice
like if you raid me with 20 viewers and
I break let's say like 500 I owe you
like so much I'll probably throw back a
raid anyway let's move on um let's try
and focus here playing bolero 1 2 3 has
some a stylish raining wait it's not
popping up sometimes I base my openings
off of my opponents raining I'm gonna
play something solid I'll play a huge ad
so one thing that if you play against
English I kind of treated as a d4
opening so White's treating this is kind
of a mainline ready there's a few things
I play here sometimes Bishop e7
sometimes taking I think I'll take it's
a solid variation c6 yeah this is so
preparation b5 there should be seven
coming in 97 and the Sun she black just
has some setup where eventually I want
to play c5 and assuming black hats in c5
then everything is happy white might try
to prevent it
we'll see what happens oh just add blue
gifting a sub to get profits I did not
even see that but things just add blue
if you're still watching I was half hour
ago I need a better system with these
like notifications 92 it's probably not
a great move even though it has purpose
it's attacking the pond
it's on leaching the bishop just seems
like no doesn't seem like a great square
for the Knights
I defend this and this and attack this
a5 is an idea even this could be an idea
there's a few nice-looking news for lack
trying to catch a c5 if take sticks I
attack the rook you'll see five ticks
take with Knight takes I take here
it looks okay I'm just trying to apply
pressure as quickly as possible now
there's a number of targets the Bishop
Queen so now I'll take with dates I mean
we might just be trading it might just
be equal
but I like box position like rook c8
aligned with the Queen yeah so this is
one of the main lines I could take with
Knight here but let's take with Queen
attack the rook and now rook c8 not
actually sure if I have a threat it
seems like I should have something
but I really don't mind this position I
mean I'll Castle relatively soon some
pressure Bishop III so no fear
it's my rook you should probably move
the Knights like 9 a4 is an idea
those b2 is kind of a target this
Knights kind of an outpost now Knight e4
is a move 94 Queen d4 this is also a
move
I feel like I should just play Bishop e7
and castle before I do anything too
fancy so if I get the rook to d8 that
would be very very nice okay I think I'm
doing a better job of not looking at the
Chad in this game mana is asking when
are you coming to SF I don't actually
know I haven't booked my trip I wanted
to find out if there's a way to get from
LA to San Francisco if there's like a
nice way to go from LA to San Francisco
if I might fly from LA or I might fly
from Palm Springs but I'm not entirely
sure yet I wanted to book like some it's
one of these luxury buses it's like a
hotel bus but it wasn't letting me book
on the websites Queen d4 okay let's
castle
oh wait sevens kind of attacked but do I
really care
I mean if castling takes a seven takes a
seven take six seven I take on b2 or
just trading yeah let's castle
and I don't really want to trade Queens
but she's waiting back with Han so it's
equal material I'm a bit more developed
and maybe never mind well I just
developed to the final minor piece and
now it's going to be some sort of
positional battle but okay there's a lot
of like tactical potential with this
position this is kind of loose this is
also kind of loose I'll play this move
just centralize it might open up Bishop
f6 might see three ideas
yeah feels wrong but I'm gonna put the
night back on a four in some sense I'm
restricted by the bishop but in another
sense I'm restricting the bishop links
simple plans just work to you it may be
Knights might be for ideas trying it in
Knight see - there's some combination of
like 9400 t8 just about improving the
pieces
there's also Knight c3 ideas cuz he
choose not defended I did participate in
mark a sermons 100 courts imal and I did
win those are very like amazing feats
that he did conjured boards took so many
hours so Knight f3
I mean let's play nights night before is
interesting because it ties down the
rook like I don't think you can play
rook see one because the pawn hangs and
if I get in night c2s eyes Rick be one
there I could win the bishop if all
these in lines like night see two rook
be one Bishop a three rook t1 I have to
manage time as well I could also take
and take on a - maybe it's takes Knight
takes
it's also rook see for ideas okay let's
take your first I'm expecting my ticks
and I might just play simple like
radiates maybe night see to anything
forcing night see - I'd see to rook be
one rook d8 right insufficient move of
III
takes oh there's some nice line like
takes takes Knight c3 rook B to hear
about the news Roxy - hmm I feel like
rook da it's just a simple move to play
first I definitely have some some
initiative like just better pieces more
targets to attack well I'm a bit down on
time and whites just trying to
consolidate but okay there's targets
like these are a bunch of different
targets like b3 trying to be solid kind
of want to play f6 maybe also g5 get
some more bits g5
you know g5 actually has a funny threat
to it play G v g5 out of nowhere the
threat is to move here let's play h5 to
move here chase away the Knights while
he's playing fast
maybe I play f5 here could I really go
all out it's taking a very unusual turn
five-o does that even work maybe it
doesn't even work as rook to you 131
Knight c3
hey it's bits ok I'm going all out every
Lord what's on rewarding g5 Wow
III so you're sacking upon light will
come to e5 I got a really speed it up
I can take and put h4 maybe you might
see to first
what to do here
make c6 also possible I see to take
stakes all right let's take twice
now we're going to get some unusual
position
you
looking at g3 ideas I mean this is
obvious g3 takes and then Bishop d6 I
play this immediately takes and then
Bishop there and then there's a knight
c6 yeah this pawn was a gone there
anyway
okay it's a fights an idea is to take
play this one in the pawn or maybe this
first and take here first the bishop can
be overworked wow Mike C to play this
move
take sticks
oh wait am i trapping the bishop bits I
can't focus on bits right now because I
have to trap a bishop wait does this
trap the vision that drops a bishop I
have 48 seconds but I think I'm winning
the bishop those are such a random
Bishop trap a5 hey I'm up a piece bring
the knight back I don't have too many
pawns to work with let's check Knight c3
[Music]
c3 let's play [ __ ] g7 better swear
against the Knights just play this move
on the Brooks coming in its defend
Knight c3 defend
oh there's tricks though let's play this
move
hmm had to move much faster much much
faster 16 seconds to hold onto the pond
whoo free Brooke ten seconds left nights
gonna be really annoying
ooh now it's gone
oh my gosh that's difficult so much
stress thank God for forks that fork
really helped out like a three I saw a
three coming it was like ooh fork and
then B three ideas - it would have been
very annoying like if I lose this last
pawn and I just have like two rocks in
the night
it's rook night in some ponds oh thanks
for the bits alright one second left
yeah thankfully this is ten minute
chests and not nine minutes 58 seconds s
it's two extra seconds really helped
thanks yeah
that's why you should learn how to check
me it was like king and rook to like
quickly I I've never played go but okay
you drink some I still have a lot of
this iced chai like coconut milk hey
it's more bits while each s / HS calm
well I mean leach s has a yearly rapid
arena right now so that's that's the
tournament of choice I still play on
Jeff's calm occasionally I see see I
used to play on like all the time but
they stopped I don't know they stopped
updating or it just became a bit less
modern so like another game but yeah I
mean nowadays I see chess commonly
chests started to like most popular
platforms Lee chess has some better like
study tools in terms of saving and like
organizing analysis but chest con has
like a lot of amazing things to between
content and
there's streamer tournaments and their
player community so it's nice that they
both exist let's not piss urk let's play
E for Carol con alright
still calming down from the previous
game play the two nights attack night at
six I have six is actually a very
playable move I'll take you five this is
some mainline play this move we might
actually transpose into a two nights
attack against the French or black will
waste a tempo playing c6 and c5 mmm at
six so bold it might be playable it just
looks like terribly wrong I want to
punish it Bishop d3 takes 9 h4 I'm just
going for the kill like Bishop d3 takes
9 h4 I don't see anything wrong with
that
I mean u6 also looks tempting the
problem is this I'm a bit overextended
and go for this just dreaming of some
meat on this diagonal
so II six this is probably one of the
best moves I'm still tempted to go for
this it's not easy to defend against
queen h5 I give a g6 I might even
consider taking f5 so f5 this is kind of
while I watched cuz now Queen h5 have g6
I can take
actually if g6 I take and it takes I
don't even take the rook I would take
back on g6 King e7 Bishop g5 I hear I'm
just winning everything
I'll even win the rook in the end man
that was such a nice scheme to have
after that the previous game a lot more
games like that just to show what I was
referring to g6 takes takes takes King 7
Bishop g5 skewer and then like I I win
the Queen and then I would never
recommend and whites just up too much
material ok that was fun yeah as far as
I know the meaning of is 94 and then I
was gonna play 92 so I remember seeing
some like GM game are they playing 92
most common move Oh Carlsen play this
Carlsen we shook wow these Center pawns
it looks like one of these like Tetris
pieces
alright kind of like the way Carlson
play this he just starts eating pawns
but these Center pawns are still like
terrifying something
how did Carlson win this look so dry was
a simple it's game oh this is ICC open
wait Internet Chess Club open people
can't see sometimes it says like the
event anyway how did he win this ooh
Bishop f4 that's a big no-no all right
back to tournament I'm so happy I have
this random challenge button now thanks
so much
whatever your name is get something
let's join the tournament again I'm
climbing the ladder I won the great 2500
in rapid be a nice nice milestone the
carrot opening f4 f5 g4 I think that
requires some cooperation from the
opponent I still need to play a French I
didn't play the French yet I've been
white in so many games
I've been white in every game I was
white I was black in that game I played
against like English white white black
in the first game too
I'm white again alright let's play e4
again slowly but surely
um let's play a knight c3 Sicilian this
is a favorite opening of mine that's
very tricky b5 usually the rule is if
they don't move their night you just
take it play d3 I want to play f4 and
nights f3 I'll have some simple
structure castle middle game plan
usually involves Queen e1 to g3 and
attack on the Kings side and black does
have the bishop parent but the bishops
aren't too impressive at least Jets clay
Queen e1
okay now maybe I should think was queen
g3 is a move Queen g3 take sticks
hmm looks reasonable yeah let's do it
I would like to take with her rook but
then there's 9 h5 if I take with Queen
then there's no 9 h5 and it's a very
nice structure and these pawns are a
little bit ugly
okay so there's some queen g4 idea could
play h3 thinking about Bishop g5 just
unleash that file and of queen g4 I win
material if black doesn't blunder I
think the plan is 92 to g3 to f5
I keep maneuvering pieces towards the
Kings side I do appreciate like book
recommendations in the chat I don't know
who asks a question but as always nice
when people help recommend books to
other people
alright h6 questioning the bishop think
about h6 is creates a target target
later on if something a night ever comes
to f5 there could be potential
sacrifices I'll play Bishop h4 I have to
be careful with this
this ice child like there's fragments of
like tea they get stuck wash it down
with more chai why so small oh I forgot
to change the scene is that better
sorry about that I have different scenes
I have different monitors so if this one
monitor it's like the whole stream Labs
OBS sometimes I forget what I've done
but as long as I'm focusing on the
chessboard that's what matters
wait did moobot break
looks like moobot broke this there's no
no available sub counts Nighy eights
wanting to trade bishops I don't think I
want to trade the ships which means I
should probably move back to g3 the
Knights a bit passive I still have my
ideas of night maneuvers conflict 92
okay so d5 was one of the moves I was
kind of waiting for because now it
allows a five and now this Knight has to
move somewhere very sad h7 or Yeats
that's still gonna take some work
g4 I didn't even consider g4 I think I
just like unconsciously rejected it
because h3 traps and lights
another drawback to him upon each
six-night would love to save itself hey
this is your first stream the strange
quark welcome to twitch good to have you
f5 I could take if I own pissant then
and that comes back so now I'm up a
piece okay for a moment there I thought
Bishop g5 traps my queen thankfully I
have Bishop back for that would have
been some insane trick if it actually
works
now Queenie for yeah life is good things
are defended I'm up a piece time is fine
honestly these 10 minute tournaments are
like really tiring I'll play a handful
of games and it just takes so much
energy even these is like easier games
but I'm trying my best
you watched a few hours of my content
whilst I was on a plane do you have
Wi-Fi or you downloaded it that's nice
though yeah I'm sure there's some
statistic like on YouTube how many hours
I've uploaded because every video all
between all the videos averages probably
at least one hour it's got to be over a
hundred hours of my content on YouTube
especially if you include the st. Louis
chess club videos
do I use Apple products yes I have an
iPhone I have air pods
I have a MacBook I think that's it just
those three yeah Apple if you want to
sponsor me be happy to help try and grow
your business Bishop takes g5 be
prepared
triple pawns are about to happen yeah
this is beautiful my blocking is all the
pawns I'll put the reclining one very
soon I should play penguin wait speaking
of iPhone oh here's my phone also
speaking of penguin I saw penguins
yesterday pretty sure I saw penguins
yesterday yeah it's not my Instagram
story penguins I sent this Fattah Tov
and she responded my baby's okay
I have some more penguin photos let's
focus on the game though it's just
getting exciting
my Knights coming into play still have
dreams of this move and maybe eventually
this move I'm not seeing any immediate
like mating ideas though maybe not h5
some trick like 9 h5 Queen g6 then
Knight f6 Queen h7 or I just like do
this and then when one of these things
why not Knight move now well it was
blacks turn but now it's my turn
so the pawns attacked
trying to calculate like Knight h5 Queen
takes Queen here hmm let's do it
wait but what's the threat though I
don't even know if I have a threat with
this move Queen g6 is off-limits
again I don't want to overthink this
also thinking about Knight f5 take
sticks even rookie eights a rookie one
let's play rook e1 the solid move and
then I draw arrows yeah right click and
drag if you hold down shift it can make
different colors or control or shift
ctrl or alt or shift alt I think these
are the four colors you could make and
they're all they all have their own like
arrow things I don't know why you would
need four colors maybe it's useful
apologies to the the colorblind people
on my BOTS
that's my pots so useful sometimes
robots these days oh you're colorblind
but it's fine for you nice
so the time advantage is growing I
forgot the hu pong is kind of hanging
hey okay three in a row it is preventing
my knife from coming in now f6 is very
weak play rook f6 player got six I mean
black has to take otherwise I win g6 now
black has to trade Queens and my knight
will be like very very stable I think is
king f7 is possible I mean everything's
winning at this point it's just a matter
of having some nice finish yeah let's
make an endgame now my king will walk up
and just have breakfast lunch and dinner
b3 prophylaxis
there's also the idea I mean if I want
to I could just take all the black pawns
with my king and then make like six
nights I'm not gonna go that far I'm not
I'm fine gold but I do have to win this
and this is actually kind of annoying
why Kings completely restricted now I
don't want to take on g3 and lose my
precious f6 pawn so I'm gonna have to go
this way and that'll be good enough you
vote for six nights I mean I want to
have time for at least a few more like
constructive games before I go insane
yeah the thing is he's just gonna move
back and forth so this is a the easiest
way to make progress trying to think
like how recently I've had quadruple
pawns pretty sure I had quadruple pawns
not too long ago in some like
competitive game too you see I think it
probably involved little Plotkin make a
new tab here I don't want to resign the
game little Plotkin oops there's no
space there we go okay nice game Nile Z
with a sub grab game next if I'm white
maybe we'll see I just want to show a
funny game um it was the most recent
game we played or maybe not oh wait no
this was games with me yeah this game is
this a game this is a game look at these
pawns it's like a Tetris piece and then
it's like another Tetris piece but the
most valuable Tetris piece is a one
that's like just a stick it's gonna
happen eventually yeah f4 so deep in
positional then takes this was like last
month was four in a row and then it was
somehow I think it was just a draw or
did I win oh I won cuz Black Flag's
thanks for the new sub Warwick fun okay
let's move on back to tournaments if I'm
white I'm playing AG Rob if I'm black
I'm playing a French the openings are
determined goodbye to chests night 22
thanks for stopping by
mmm I'll have a French I'll pre-movie
six and it's a French okay why do I
transpose into a Sicilian no let's stay
with a French ah the exchange variation
I'm not a huge fan of the exchange
variation for either color this is why a
lot of people don't play the French
however there is a way to play this to
make it dynamic and the plan is to play
knight c6 Bishop g4 Queen d7 Castle
queenside start with knight c6 here
maybe even Bishop f5 try and trade off
like White's best Bishop now Queen d7
yeah like this we're actually gonna have
like a an interesting
hopefully sharp position and that's kind
of what you want against someone who's
playing this sort of style that move
kind of scares me though this could be
annoying do I castle into White's attack
do I go insane and just take on h3 right
away I could Castle kingside still and
be safe choices choices I could take on
d3 9 of 5
I think this is okay I'm gonna castle
I'm just trying to evaluate like what
happens when my time comes to a five I
think there's many cases where I'll just
have that post on c4 and b5 could
actually be a target exchange French
barf yeah we need it in exchange French
barf emotes that'd be too much to fit
into one emote be an interesting design
challenge all right so it's like pawn
storming I mean this looks kind of
artificial it's like a Christmas tree
looks like a tree but it's not actually
a tree hey test Oh Viren don't think
donating $10 saying why hello there
well thanks for your donation what do I
do
I mean now maybe sacking is a
possibility also this is a possibility
night g6g 5 is a possibility I might
play g5 without even being bribed like
g5g for miles lead will be happy love a
chest will be happy Henry Lord Bataan
will be happy g5 g4 how badly will I be
punished for that
g5 I mean the knight or Bishop can take
and but then I have ripped g8 let's play
g5 the thing is because of pawns on h3g
fives so much more attractive because g4
will guarantee open the file the rook
will come to g8 and it's all about
opening the file I don't care about a
pond or losing a pond I just care about
meeting the king
and did you ask why here what would
happen if white takes yeah I mean this
is like the first question to ask like
what to do if white just takes a free
pawn but I think rook GA that's it's
nice it has some initiative
I might even sacrifice f7 like Knight
takes g5 appreciate Knight takes f7
Bishop takes h3 and the TAC is alive and
100 bits g5 lives on
I mean g5 might not live for so long but
I'll have an attack in its honor
so Bishop takes g5 so now it's a
question which work do I move if I move
this rook Bishop f6 may be playable move
this rook let's move this rook so now
the thread is h6 make the bishop move
when this pawn so the very nice x-ray
vision here like the combination of both
bishops
even the Queen the rook
even the light come in there's so much
potential and this is like a dream come
true scenario when you play the exchange
French like you barf a little bit but
then you feel better b5 so b5 985 I kind
of want to just ignore it and go crazy
but let's save the night
blockading White's pawn storm enabling
night c4 potential it's very hard to
remove this Knight and Kings quite safe
I do have to watch out for like ease
forcing trades it takes I probably have
to take with Bishop okay this is
interesting now because if I want to
maybe I can get away with this like
takes takes f6 always play off six
Knight controls f5 if takes takes takes
and there's a pin let's do it
I don't see anything wrong with it maybe
this could fall it could still get very
strange if Bishop takes h7 probably rook
g7 so here I have h6 or f6 I'm actually
sure which is better
Tirana play f6 just to prove it to been
fine gold but h6 I want to open the H
file because h3 is long-term targets I
could also just take and then the
bishops still pinned the Knights attacks
there's so many good-looking options
here this might be the way to go
actually like Queen takes h3 just leave
everything as is there is no Bishop f5
the King's completely stocked the
Knights stuck bishops pinned everything
is paralyzed a queen takes h3 this was
not my initial plan but I'm actually
threatening like made into frightening
force made into and it's not easy for a
white to get out of because so many
things just can't move like the Knights
tied down to defending this okay so rook
e1 was maybe the only try now I'm trying
to calculate the slide like takes takes
Bishop h2 the problem is a knight would
be attacking my queen I mean I could
just take the Knights this looks
completely winning also looking at the
slime I hear it takes takes king h1 rook
here I mean let's just take the Knights
a simple approach
so I won back the piece now this is
falling
that's a nice game it all started with
g5 and I feel like g5 it's the type of
move that mean I've been playing it
recently it's just like probably dubious
but it may have actually been the best
move in that position
I wasn't Bishop e2 meeting Bishop h2
visual aid student Knight takes h2 or
even like King here I should be shoe
King H 1 I'm sure it's probably winning
somehow wasn't nice bunch of h2 takes
maybe it's the line that I said yeah
maybe now I'm not meeting my force but
I'm still having fun there okay some
little piece
just looking for mates queen h1 ideas
queen g2 ideas mmm takes a little bit
more work
like we teach one I'm probably bring the
night in Gary to do this
the other night might come in at some
points some potential mate with the two
nights if Bishop f5 check I probably
just take it and then afford to follow
mmm do I actually want to take it cuz
Queen that five comes with check let's
just do it
King be it King safety first
now the Knights will show their
dominance
maybe night see four and then this so
many possibilities I didn't realize I
was spending a lot of time this scheme
where all my time was spent why did I
sock for exchange just for fun because
now the the bishop can't really restrict
my Knights
and I that for is very hard to stop if
work out three probably rookie eights I
mean we could have some fun calculating
so the vengeful mates like somewhere
yeah so King D to Queenie one King c2
rookie to King D three Queen D 192 and
then mates so it goes back to III now
there's actually a problem like I want
to play Knight at four but then there's
Queen takes off for and that would be
slightly tragic so I could take
hmm that's tricky let's just play a safe
move
now I can go in I do have to watch out
for Baccarin commute though I don't want
to embarrass myself too much start with
9 F for King D to only move and then
trying to figure out the mate here as
might see 14 C 2 takes takes rook G 2
but my queen comes in from behind and
can finish things off G 2 Queen D 1
alright so that was nice
it took some effort there I'm really
curious what stockfish thinks about this
g5 food because it is actually somewhat
thematic well Bishop takes h3 was there
for a moment f6 so g5 playable oh maybe
it likes g5 it doesn't see g5 at first
but now it sees it oh now it really sees
it yeah sometimes moves like this but
you sock a pawn for like some
longer-term compensation but yeah a
stock fish is just really confused
proudly in this position you know Bishop
takes g5
Wow so I could have taken here at
medially tanks Wow the attacks just too
strong like White has an extra tempo
compared to the game but this is still
probably just unstoppable
well I have played g5 if Carlson was my
opponent that's hard to answer I mean if
someone was bribing me with bits and
probably but even still like yeah it's
the type of move I'd probably be happy
to play against a strong player because
when you think about it even this line
it's just so difficult for whites like
these ideas it's just the open file is
so much more valuable than the pond is
it even is it theory this could be some
theoretical position would be surprised
maybe I'll me chess so this has been
played many times before I meet chess
queenside castling a for g5 novelty I'm
so happy it's a novelty it's like the
top move - so this is only getting kudos
to Lee chess for like updating the
database right away - all right do I
play one more
what um let's play one more
uno mas back to tournaments being so far
all of my opponents have been below mm
oh let's play a London in this game oh I
forgot to play the Grob
I'm so sorry miles e and k Bom
I'm playing a London I want to be solid
can you unsub I don't think you can
unsub after he like subbing but I'm so
sorry play this move he's six blocks
playing quickly I'm just gonna play like
the normal setup see 392 don't think a
six is considered to be like that's
dangerous maybe arguably just a waste of
time
b5 isn't too threatening
now this is a question what to do here I
don't really want to castle right away
because then after take stakes I Rick's
not on the h-file I think I look like we
need to
it's like normally the most flexible
move and then usually when black is
preparing e5 the move to play as Knight
e5 just blocking in the pawn Queen c7
okay this is very standard London stuff
lots of pressure on e5 on f4 is kind of
the go-to move I think I'll just do it
like why not and there's some trap
coming up I won't say it because maybe
black is watching okay so blocks not
falling into it right away and usually
the rule is you should take back with
this pawn on each of the Queen taking
with the C pawn and sometimes allows
Knight be for this looks really Pleasant
though nyeeehhh for sacking a pawn so I
was going to say the trap uh would be 97
which looks logical just runs into this
followed by Queen here and takes Knight
e4 I think I'm just running a pawn could
take with Knight or Bishop probably take
with Knight first if I take with Queen
on threatening h7
and black has to do something ugly like
g6 or f5 f5 now my night is very stable
because black never has f6 up upon to
like might take take back should be
southern castle and the game will go on
another sub Montes Aris Rex slumming
with twitch prime do you appreciate that
what made you like the London when you
first started playing it yeah this was
back maybe around 2015 like mid 2015 I
started playing the London because I
realized how many like traps there are
especially high level traps like I was
looking up some like main lines and in
some of the main lines like if you turn
on the engine the computer is finding
like these very interesting ideas and
then they proved to be the case like a
lot of strong players still in the
falling for for various traps I gave a
lecture where I basically show a lot of
examples like this for the st. Louis
chess club YouTube channel it's called
something like how to be good players
with the London I think I'll just Castle
here no need to do anything fancy
I think the the first like very high
level player to play the London
consistently before people realized
that's a very dangerous weapon was calm
ski when calm ski was actually
interviewed pretty recently on the
perpetual chest podcast and I was
talking about like how he kind of
pioneered the London and he was gonna
write a book on it but so many other
people wrote books on its that there has
no need
the London has many counter place
if by counter players you mean like
responses from black yeah there's a
number of ways black can meet the London
but it's more complex and a lot of
people think with every line there's
nuances can always like learn a higher
level okay so I like the structure like
being up upon like having the bishop
hair I think this Bishop probably wants
to be on this diagonal can the knight
wants to come here
maybe I should preserve c4 so what to do
Bishop h4
improve my a rook yeah there's a very
clear like plan for black I think I'll
start with Bishop c4 actually as if
Knight moves here I just take and the
bishops now tied down to defending the
e6 pawn and there might be some eventual
like tricks like Bishop here and then
takes and maybe when f5 yeah just an
easier position to play for whites what
do I think of the Dutch defense
yeah the Dutch defense is like at least
of the high levels it's an opening that
if black plays and blacks trying to play
for a win
we saw it played at the US Championships
both Caruana and Nakamura played it with
success like Fabiano beat um ooh did he
beat oh he be the KO beam with the Dutch
and Nakamura beat Geoffrey Zhang with
the Dutch because when the pawns on f5
and just imbalances the position in this
case this looks like a free pawn rook
takes f5 you always have to be careful
like when you're relying on tactics like
this like okay takes Queen takes e4 I'm
happy takes and b5 Bishop here I don't
think there's any effective way to like
remove the bishop okay so let's do it
ah there's one line I didn't calculate
thankfully I don't think it works for
lack are there's this move which does
attempt to throw me off balance
thankfully I can just take and attacking
the rook and then we're just trading
stuff probably should have seen that
beforehand no I'll save the rook and I'm
of two pawns threatening to win a third
pawn and now that file is open which is
really nice I got one maybe I should
play a three first the a3 is a nice
prophylactic move kills on the counter
play before can now never be played and
yet let's double up
what do I think of the woodpecker method
honestly I don't know enough about it to
like have a comment I've heard very good
things about it I've heard good things
from like people who I know and I I
trust so it's something that I've I've
recommended even though I haven't like
looked so deeply into it myself
if anyone's interested I would recommend
looking at coast chuck boot skis twitch
channel because he's going through the
whole thing
and it's tedious but he's streaming
himself like I think a couple hours
every day or a couple hours every other
day and like it's one of those things if
you put in the time and network I think
you can have a very big impact on your
tactical abilities let's play h4 I want
to play h5 and create some eventual
weakness the the name or the twitch
channel I know is there a shout out
command s oh hello coast yeah
oh no it's just twitch TV slash hello
coast yeah there you go alright so we
can trade everything takes takes takes I
don't know if I want to trade Queens Oh
probably want to keep Queens on the
board you take first
yeah let's keep Queens on the board does
e6 is vulnerable it's just easier to
attack with Queens this is a yearly
rapid arena if you want to play it
there's two hours left in the tournament
people can see here it's an eight hour
long tournament I've only played for the
last a couple hours
Lance is leading by a lot I'll share a
link in the chat if anyone wants to play
okay so we're probably going to be
trading like everything takes takes I
play h5 yeah keeping some initiative
like takes okay now I just wanted me in
on g7 what's the uptime command
well time is a command to just type in
um
exclamation point uptime it did take me
a while to learn all this like when I
was new to twitch cow commands work
alright I think we're gonna end up
trading Queens and I'll have to grind
things down or maybe I could like go for
I do this this this this and then Bishop
f6
or just h6 right away let's play Bishop
h4 it's a little bit risky but I think
it'll lead to a quicker win as I'm
sacking potentially like three pawns but
I'm going for the meat again
I really haven't been paying attention
to time time is about level MBLAQ has
some decision to make I think
everything's losing her back it's just a
question how he wants to lose like going
for this here it's basically like dying
slowly or dying quickly or like think
queen d1 hoping I don't realize he's
attacking my queen
yeah ratings are all relative they can
be different depending on the platform
aah - looks reasonable no more checks
Queen h6 I of Bishop g5 so King f7
interesting to play this move
maybe Bishop g5 first trying to chase
the Queen away from f3
let me give Queen e1 Queen a3 and I
would be 7 so Queen d3 is expected and
anytime I can trade Queens
maybe my bishop can like come around but
maybe that's too fancy trying to find a
way to attack this pawn
each six ideas the queen up for king
queen up for King Yates age six
maybe I just like placed some waiting
move like Bishop here
it's very patience I'm just putting the
ball lock in back in blacks courts
there's one idea to play Queen g5 Queen
e7 so blocks just waiting just six I
should probably just move quicker keep
waiting a little bit I'm waiting for
some opportunity so don't really want to
play Queen a3 eventually
hey Queen f3 will come not sure how
strong it is
I'll attack b7 black when this may be
queen f2 actually Queen f2 now I go for
the Queen trade and I'll move faster for
both getting low on time
black doesn't take play this move tak
the pawn
you
King h3 it looks weird but I want to fly
queen g4 I had so many opportunities to
trade Queens earlier now it's time oh he
wants to play Knight see foreign witness
me Bishop
h4 here Queen a 5 g 4 queen bee one
comment
interesting let's play this move now I
can take what are the odds mighty five
and Queenie eight will come yes this is
only moved to defend no threats then
Bishop H for the Queen can't stay the
fending hey Queenie eights okay
took some effort there like towards the
end
pony for the resistance I think in this
position Queenie you want it's actually
a little bit tricky cuz might see four
comes and then there's threats of Queen
each one but okay let's all a game all
around I was never in trouble
alright there's a lot of chess I have to
hit the road I have five hours of
driving tonight did I start another game
oh no I started another game I don't
know how I did that
yes I had the thing open another tab Oh
play one more game I was gonna end the
stream let's play aggressive I don't
want this to last another twenty minutes
my ggressive open can i play
maybe I should I've see fourth place um
molar attack I guess
you want a scotch I'll play a scotch
each sixes is a mic comer move I think
there's some old like st. Louis Chess
Club videos
he says play h6 and inspire like a new
generation of dubious players
yeah h6 was just slow and I think d4 is
the best way to me that and just open
the center and there's all there's
there's actually a lot of tactical traps
that that can fall into this being one
of them
some people like take and play b6 Wow
95 let's move back I want to punish this
night it's not defended it's in the
center
maybe there's queen h5 ideas Knight f6
so now this looks very attractive like
f4 and Knight moves be 5 it's like a
Halloween gambit but I didn't sacrifice
any piece just have to calculate this
ticks here here g3 Knight xg3 Knight f3
it should be good enough
it's platfor and again I don't want us
like spend so much time calculating I
just want to like win quickly realizing
if Knight takes e4 maybe I would play
Queenie to first or even queen h5 first
okay but this will be fun
good take likely five immediately takes
pawn takes
there's also Knight f5 let's play e5
I'll just dominate the center if Queenie
seven of nine to five
if takes I'll take back nine missus uh
maybe I missed a few sub notifications I
think there they were from a while ago
but thanks Gator Alex I don't think I
mentioned that name how was a while ago
now that five is ass winning nine f5
there is queen bee for Jack Queen before
Knight c3
according before I want to play Bishop
d2
I'm busy busy turns into Queenie
forecheck so Knight c3 defends e4 the
light still attacks light has very few
squares like awesome these are the only
two safe squares I'm controlling these
oh wait a minute there's this move but
if this move I have this move things get
really messy actually actually 94 I can
take on at 7 King takes f7 then Queen d5
so yeah maybe the Chi eight will come
there's some funny idea like night whoa
okay so this is being counter-attacked
so can I counter counter-attack with
this move let's do it why not a three
the Queen doesn't have so many squares
and these are the only squares it could
move to so all these squares are
off-limits I don't think I'm trapping
the Queen unless I am trapping the Queen
Bishop e3 now this is the only safe
Square oh there's some interesting idea
I don't know if it works though but
Queen a5 there's Bishop takes f7 King
takes f7 then b4 promise might takes
before it takes before Queen takes
before that's kind of a mess I could
play this move preparing before I could
take the knight
I mean it's a great position I just want
to win quickly defend the Knights and d6
is clever move
so takes takes
I mean if I just move my light back all
that takes it's a strange situation so
you really don't want to trade in Bishop
a4 how hopeful is Bishop a4 Bishop takes
and then b4 I just win the Queen right
queen would be trapped let's do it
such a weird move like the bishop seems
like it should be here but let's do it
oh wait the Queen's not trapped Queen a6
is playable so here takes b4 queen a sex
with them Bishop e5 chops of Queen and
if it takes takes Knight still hanging
pawns hanging I should be okay yeah so
it's weird cuz like the Knights attacked
this night's attacks I didn't defend I
didn't take I'm just making other
threats and this is nice multi-purpose
move like align with the King and pin
the knight so now there's no more night
sacrifice
now I didn't consider like the counter
counter counter attacks these moves but
I assume I just move my queen so the
Queen will be trapped sack the bish what
does this emotes alright
there should be five winning the Queen
yeah the Queen gather a little bit too
adventurous and it's gonna be nice
having the Queen what am i drinking I
showed this a while ago I'm drinking
iced chai toasted coconut almond milk
it's vegan it's um it's GMO it's a
little bit spicy it's sugar-free it's a
little bit sweet - whoa
so if I take - here takes here that's
kind of a mess oh I don't want to deal
with complaints of G one Bishop G one's
a funny move all these weird moves
Bishop G one the idea is that I'm
threatening to trout the night with H
three I'm still threatening to take on
c7 so black does have two pieces for the
Queen but I think I'm winning material
here unless there's counter-attacks
[Music]
it's interesting so h3 takes and Queenie
to looks a little bit risky Oh with a
night of 6mm you have to be somewhat
careful castling queenside was a good
move by Queen d5 taking on a 7 also
looks a little bit exotic but Yolo
it actually looks kind of fun if I do
get to take on a 7 then I take the
bishop there's some idea like Bishop e6
here here and then f5
yeah looks reasonable okay so takes I
hope I'm not blundering anything like my
king is a little bit shaky but I mean
everything looks controlled I'm
attacking the bishop
I still have ideas of h3 also a7 is kind
of vulnerable to the bishop moves bishop
can move places I'm on the queenside
castle it's not going to be legal
because the rooks controlling d1
oh my downtime I was trying to move
quickly this game every game I'm getting
like the low for three minutes okay so
he saw the main threat hoping he would
see it maybe now Castle queenside just
apply some pressure this Bishop spin to
the pawn not sure if I have any
immediate threats I mean if we tray and
then I'll again be attacking c7 pond
there won't actually be a great way to
defend like takes takes Bishop d6 Knight
takes c6 and it takes takes okay we'll
have this if 95 then I can take on a 7
yeah life is good hello - emerald moon
I'm sure there's a lot of people who
also said hi so hi to everyone okay
I could take some funny line takes takes
and then like Bishop b6 in the end yeah
let's have some fun
oh if takes I take on e5 so I'm
expecting King BA takes takes and Bishop
to b6 it's a nice move if Bishop d6 I
can take if rook c8 I win d7 that's very
difficult for black it's a problem with
being down a queen it's now take here
maybe in the night we'll return I want
to play b5 maybe eventually b6 r b5
Bishop e6 life is good is there a
schedule for streams I do have a
schedule but it's not updated I should
probably put in the live events too
because I'll be in San Francisco I'll be
in Nashville probably the Nashville
event should be there actually so if b5
Bishop here
Quincy for
hmm
I'm just trying to be accurate I mean
maybe just Bishop Bishop d4 takes Queen
takes Bishop Bishop g4 I can take yeah
you can go for that I'm preventing
Bishop f6 I'm trying to tempt black to
take and then I take back with Queen
even there's some line like takes takes
Bishop c6 Queen a7 just going for a
quick meet or I would g7 Bishop g5 king
b1
you should g4 wow so g4 can I played b5
takes takes I'll lose some material but
I get some attack I blade work t32 but
then takes takes Bishop f6 other than I
can take on d8 also can I take on g7
here does that work like counter-attack
the rook it takes two you one takes gh8
I think that works you're up G and I
just take on d8 yeah kind of strange
sequence I'm growing my collection of
pawns Queen and two pawns four four nine
and Bishop not looking good for g5 I
mean I'm still like capable maybe at
some point actually g5 might be like the
eventual winning plant like breaking
through and making another Queen that's
going to take some preparation though I
my opponent my flag before I get in g5
you play this move try and trade rooks
no this is sneaky b5 play the smooth a
lot of things are in the way of the G
font our precious Jeep on Bishop e6 is a
free Bishop takes rook t1 and I just
king you two and this Bishop defends
from a distance not that my King needs
like so much defending let's play Queen
b3 be extra I don't wanna lose my G pawn
though well let's be fancy I'll play
rookie - very fancy move
if takes you to queen g4 now let's play
h4 advance the King side majority the
bishop is almost trapped like Queen h3
check and then this move remove the
guard okay what are the odds that g5
will be the final move of the game
I guess not I got in g5 though not like
it mattered okay let's go for the kill
went for the flag all right that was a
long game I didn't think that was gonna
take 20 minutes but I kind of did a
thousand bits from Henry Lord what time
thanks for the fits is that because I
played g5 the very end all right I think
we're gonna wrap things up I do
appreciate like there's this nice
viewership this only happens once a year
the yearly rapid arena I'm in the pawza
tournament so I don't accidentally start
another game penguin is streaming also
heartwise a noodle with a thousand bits
thanks so much heart wise a noodle yeah
there's some other people streaming I'm
actually now conflicted because I
there's so many people who I really
admire
I could I could raid I don't know I hate
making decisions like this where's
penguin there's Anna Rudolph
there's cocea there's Anna chess I've
been traded I've been traded a man chess
in a while I'll show some love last time
I saw Anna we were I was like it was
World Championships I think in London
okay I got this username I'll be doing
more streams in the future thanks guys
for watching
trying to think of if I have any other
announcements I'll be updating my stream
schedule shortly
I've been streaming like almost every
every day every other day
sometimes faradic but yeah stay tuned
I'll be putting out more YouTube videos
too there's been a lot of streams
recently I I have like nice YouTube
content for so oh yeah for the people
watching on YouTube in the future if you
are if I put this on YouTube
I hope you enjoy this and for the twitch
people watching thanks for watching and
good bye